[Musique]
conjuguer management et intelligence
émotionnelle est le sujet qui nous anime
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que cette
conjugaison de compétences que l'on
appelle aussi savoir être n'est pas inné
l'intelligence émotionnelle ne viennent
pas de notre héritage culturel
celui ci est plutôt le résultat de la
culture classique cartésienne qui défend
les mathématiques et qui impose un
raisonnement rationnel assez hostile aux
affects aussi discerner des mails et
comprendre rapidement voilà un ensemble
de capacités cognitives qui définissent
l'intelligence ou cuit pour la plupart
d'entre nous le dualisme or la question
se pose depuis plusieurs années de
telles dispositions permettent elles de
prendre à coup sûr de bonnes décisions
de faire des choix éclairés de faire des
choix les moins conditionné possible de
bien managé ses projets ses équipes car
l'intelligence émotionnelle est une
compétence entière du management un
véritable axe d'amélioration un
véritable amélioration de vie au travail
pour soi pour ses équipes
fini le temps du management directif
descendants voire autoritaire mais
revenons à nos philosophes pour spinoza
les émotions sont le fondement même de
la survie et de la culture humaine
elle nous met en garde contre les
mauvais choix l'intelligence
émotionnelle est aussi une intelligence
sociale car dès lors qu'elle est mise en
oeuvre en contexte interpersonnelles
elle s'entrelacent avec toutes les
qualités qui permettent de mieux
connaître mieux comprendre soi et les
autres
l'intelligence émotionnelle est une part
très importante du comportement de
l'épaisseur de la relation de la manière
dont nous agissons
elle conditionne beaucoup de choses bien
entendu aussi réapprendre apprendre les
fondamentaux de l'intelligence
émotionnelle et sociale est un moyen de
développer sa capacité à être pleinement
concentré sur son action sur la
situation et les personnes qu'elles
impliquent
c'est un moyen de développer sa capacité
à transmettre et à créer un
environnement favorable à la circulation
de l'information entre les protagonistes
c'est encore un moyen de développer sa
capacité à entendre et prendre en compte
toutes les formes de signaux émis par
l'environnement
les individus qui évolue sans préjuger
de leur valeur cette compréhension de
l'autre nous permet en
en plus d'interpréter les indices
d'émotionnel et de les accompagner avec
respect et empathie cependant cette
disposition n'est pas aisé pour tous et
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
souhaité illustrer rapidement les quatre
grands axes des profils de personnalités
commençons d'abord avec notre profil
dominant qui est un profil plutôt solide
qui est fort qui va porter sur lui les
problèmes à bras le corps un qui va les
porter à bras le corps et qui aura
tendance à se fermer devant toutes les
émotions les siennes et celles des
autres il va se protéger il sera donc
dans une zone d'efforts à développer sa
capacité que l'on appelle l'intelligence
émotionnelle ou savoir être en revanche
pour le profil influente
c'est un profil qui est dans la relation
à l'autre c'est un profil qui est sur un
tempo rapide lui aussi et qui va cumuler
le réseau le le plaisir d'être dans la
relation est donc pour lui
l'intelligence émotionnelle sera une
faculté aisée une faculté qui sera
plutôt inné de la même façon pour notre
profil stable qui est un profil dans
l'empathie qui est dans l'aide qui est
un profil très à l'écouté qui est dans
la compréhension même de l'autre avant
même d'être dans la sienne donc il sera
peut-être un peu plus sous assertif mais
en moins il est dans des dispositions et
zé pour être dans la compréhension et
dans l'intelligence émotionnelle ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour notre profil
conscient qui lui sera en zone d fork
arrivés dans la discrétion il est dans
le retrait il est dans l'analyse il a
besoin du système il a besoin du cadre
et ce profil n'est pas du tout dans
l'intelligence émotionnelle
non pas qu'il n'ait pas envie d'y être
mais ça n'est pas encore une fois la
partie la plus aisée pour lui en plus de
cela en plus de la compréhension des
autres il y à la compréhension des
gouvernances de l' orchestre neuronale
gouvernance des émotions qui sont bien
entendu des ressources ressources du
d'abord pour la gouvernance instinctive
et qui va nous indiquer que à un moment
donné nous avons des besoins des besoins
vitaux des besoins de base et qu'il faut
satisfaire et que nous avons aussi des
instincts de survie qui sont là pour me
protéger instinct de survie qui vont
nous alerter
lorsque nous sommes en danger ça va
provoquer chez nous l'action de suite
instinct de survie lorsque nous sommes
en colère ou agressé qui va provoquer
chez nous l'action de lutte est encore
l'un stand inhibition lorsque nous
sommes dans une grande détresse grande
tristesse
évidemment ses instincts là on peut
travailler dessus et on peut juguler les
effets qu'ils ont sur nous et les
conséquences qu'ils ont sur notre
environnement
il y a aussi la gouvernance grégaire qui
détermine notre positionnement dans le
groupe
notre rapport au monde en fonction de la
manière dont selon se voit dont on se
sent que l'on soit en confiance ou en
défiance à son égard et vis-à-vis des
autres ça va déterminer notre rapport au
monde
ça aussi c'est une gouvernance sur
laquelle on peut travailler et que l'on
développe en intelligence émotionnelle
il y a ensuite notre gouvernance
émotionnelle la pure qui est notre
disque dur celle que spinoza défend
corps et âme
défendez celle que freud lacan et bien
d'autres ont reprises parce qu'elle est
le centre de notre épaisseur cette
gouvernance émotionnelle est le lieu de
nos expériences
elle est le lieu de tous ceux que nous
avons engrangé le lieu de nos
connaissances connaissance qui vont être
du point de vue expérimental des
connaissances et pef et du point de vue
émotionnel aussi des connaissances
épaisse
alors on se demande à quel moment est ce
que l'on revient sur la partie
rationnelle sur la partie raisonnée et
bien cette gouvernance adaptative nous
fait sortir du mode automatique que nous
avons vu précédemment que ce soit la
gouvernance grégaire la gouvernance
émotionnel ou la gouvernance instinctive
elle s'active ces trois là lorsque nous
sonnes lorsque nous sommes en zone de
confort dès lors que nous sortons de
cette zone de confort et que nous
entrons dans une zone des ford effort
intellectuel d'inconnus cette
gouvernance adaptative prend le relais
et elle va bien entendu activé notre
réflexion elle va nous faire sortir du
cadre
elle va activer notre capacité à
anticiper est dans la curiosité elle va
nous permettre de comprendre et de
rechercher bien entendu il faut savoir
alterner les registres entre gouvernance
émotionnel grégaire adaptative et
instinctive et gouvernance adaptative
faire la bascule c'est sa capacité à
sortir du cadre automatique à être
rationnel et être rationnel ce n'est pas
se couper des émotions comme le disait
descartes même si ils partagent l'idée
qu'elle existe le cerveau qui pense le
cerveau qui calcule le cerveau qui
décident n'est pas autre chose que celui
qui rit que celui qui pleure que celui
qui n qui éprouve du plaisir et du
déplaisir alors l'émotion
on va voir quelle est son processus
levier puissant du développement de la
relation humaine dans les organisations
je le répète compétences entière du
management véritable axe d'amélioration
de la vie au travail
les émotions sont tout d'abord provoqué
par une situation par un événement nous
allons réagir alors gouvernance
émotionnel gouvernance instinctive vont
réagir fortement face à la situation et
elles vont nous donner une
interprétation de ce qui se joue alors
que la gouvernance adaptatif va nous
permettre de prendre du recul et donc de
réfléchir gouvernance émotionnel va
provoquer de la réaction gouvernance
adaptative va provoquer de la réaction
donc par conséquent face à un événement
que l'on va interpréter plus ou moins
fort il est important bien entendu de
faire la bascule entre la gouvernance
instinctive et la gouvernance adaptatif
ou plutôt le mode automatique et le mode
adaptatif parce que lorsque nous sommes
en mode adaptatif donc on sort du cadre
émotionnel en gardant en tête quand même
ce qui se passe en nous ça nous permet
d'être dans un comportement qui va être
associé à sa juste mesure à la situation
d'être dans une émotion juguler
néanmoins rester à l'écouté de soi et
bien entendu rester à l'écouté des
autres alors comment est-ce que l'on va
gérer cette émotion les cinq étapes qui
s'affiche devant nous sont tout d'abord
de faire le diagnostic diagnostic de la
situation de reconnaître et de
d'accepter ce que l'on ressent au moment
où ça se produit mais bien entendu de
savoir que pour l'autre il se produit
aussi un phénomène d'émotion donc à
retenir que les manifestations de
l'émotion ont des conséquences sur moi
mais elles ont aussi des conséquences
sur les autres sur mon environnement
d'où la nécessité de prendre du recul et
d'être vraiment dans l'analyse donc pas
requis adaptative de notre gouvernance
et lorsque je ressens ses émotions que
je prends du recul que je fais cette
diagnostic je les comprends je comprend
ce qui se joue en moi et je comprends à
quel situation elles vont être associés
j'analyse leur intensité et j'anticipe
les effets que ce soit de la colère que
ça soit de la tristesse que ça soit de
l'apr j'analyse les effets qu'elles vont
produire et surtout est-ce que les
effets qui se joue en moi sont à la
hauteur de la situation qui est en train
de se dérouler est-ce que je ne suis pas
dans la sueur émotions ou dans la souris
motion est ce que celui à qui je
m'adresse n'est pas dans une sur
émotions ou dans une soute et motions
donc c'est un levier qu'il faut activer
pour comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
relation interpersonnelle et bien
entendu je choisis les bonnes émotions
qui vont être adaptés à la bonne
situation pour gérer et influencer ce
qui se joue est donc géré influencer ses
venir sur la partie rationnelle sur la
partie intelligence pure mais en gardant
dans notre intelligence pure
cette bascule systématique qui nous
amène vers l'intelligence émotionnelle
qui nous amène vers ce savoir être et
qui nous permet d'être dans du
management humain dans du management
durable
alors pour conclure penser en dehors du
cadre c'est notre capacité à prendre du
recul
je le redis à faire des choix éclairés à
penser l'autre a pensé le management
autrement à se penser soit je vous
remercie
alors pour conclure penser en dehors du
cadre c'est notre capacité à prendre du
recul je le redis à faire des choix
éclairés à penser l'autre a pensé le
management autrement à se penser soit je
vous remercie